bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat pour une journée et
une soirée spéciale autour de la séance
ici au palais du luxembourg
dans quelques instants nous allons
rejoindre l'hémicycle du sénat pour
suivre les questions cribles consacrée
aujourd'hui à l'industrie pharmaceutique
c'est marisol touraine qui répondra aux
questions des sénateurs et puis à partir
de 16h c'est le début de l'examen au
sénat du texte du projet de loi
mariage pour tous une séance que vous
allez bien sûr pouvoir suivre en
intégralité et en direct sur notre
antenne à partir de 16h et jusqu'à 23h30
ce soir nous reviendrons aussi largement
sur ce projet de loi
mariage pour tous sur notre antenne avec
des invités dans cette salle de
conférences des intervenants bref tous
les aspects du projet de loi seront
traitées sur notre antenne voilà la
séance des questions cribles sur
l'industrie pharmaceutique commence dans
l'hémicycle je vous rappelle qu'il ya eu
récemment encore des scandales comme
celui du médiator ou autour de la pilule
de troisième génération donc on va
écouter sur ces points là quelles sont
les questions des sénateurs à marisol
touraine la ministre de la santé
à tout à l'heure par l'un des membres de
son groupe politique et ce débat est
retransmis bien sûr sur la chaîne public
sénat sur france 3 nous souhaitons donc
je vous demande de bien vouloir
respecter vos temps de parole pour la
première question
la parole est un monsieur françois
fortassin pour le groupe du rdse
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues médiator
proposons aux tests de ma mère pip plus
récemment pilule de troisième quatrième
génération ces affaires ont révélé
défaillant sur le système sanitaire et
les liens étroits entre les laboratoires
certains experts médicaux dans le
scandale du médiator l'agencé nationale
de la sécurité du médicament vient
d'être mise en examen pour homicides et
blessures involontaires ainsi que deux
de ses anciens salariés pour prise
illégale d'intérêts dans la sphère des
pilules de 3ème et 4ème et 3ème
générations
comment se fait-il qu'en dépit des mises
en garde des autorités de santé depuis
des médecins ont continué de les
prescrire largement alors jeune patient
il semble que les alerte sur la
dangerosité de ces contraceptifs ont été
couvertes par une autre musique
le discours rassurant de quelques
leaders d'opinion en gynécologie donc
une enquête récente révèle les liens
étroits avec les laboratoires
cela pose la question tout comme
d'ailleurs la lecture des déclarations
publiques intérêts de certains membres
de l' agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament
même si j'entends bien que le lien
d'intérêt ne veut pas dire conflits
d'intérêts transparence c'est le mot clé
de la loi bertram décembre 2012 dans la
foulée du scandale du médiator
c'est évidemment le minimum pour
prévenir les conflits d'intérêts le
dépôt d'une déclaration publique
d'intérêts n'a de sens que si un
contrôle rigoureux est possible et
effectif madame la ministre comment
assurer un tel contrôle tous les
organismes de recherche expertise l'état
dispositif d'un comité de déontologie
au niveau de la transparence à la
française qui oblige les laboratoires a
publié des conventions qu'il passe avec
des médecins et les avantages que leur
procure où en est-on du décret
d'application en octobre dernier
certaines dans l'ordre national des
médecins craignaient que le sushi ne
soit édulcoré par rapport à la volonté
législateur avec les mécanismes savane
de cumul de tranches de seuil qui
permettrait ne permettrait pas au public
de connaître l'essor effectivement
versées par les industriels aux
professionnels de santé
enfin que dire de ces journées de
formation des visiteurs médicaux qui ne
sont en réalité que des séminaires de
motivation souvent organisés dans des
lieux exotiques et est dans le coup tu
quittes sont destinés à mobiliser les
troupes et dont le coût s'est répercuté
sur le prix des médicaments
enfin les primes golf en fonction des
objectifs à atteindre dans ce contexte
actuel de défiance quasi généralisée que
pouvez vous nous dire madame la ministre
sur tous ces points si pour vous
répondre la parole à madame marisol
touraine ministres affaires sociales et
de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur françois fortassin
il est exact que des affaires
santons ont occupé le devant de la scène
et provoquer de la défiance de la part
de nos concitoyens envers à la fois les
médicaments envers les professionnels de
santé et nos concitoyens s'interroge sur
les liens qui peuvent unir l'industrie
pharmaceutique et certains
professionnels de santé
comme vous l'avez vous-même indiqué il
ne s'agit pas d'interdire par principe
que des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
puisse travailler avec des médecins
implique soit hospitaliers ou libéraux
en revanche il faut que la transparence
la plus absolue soit réalisé sur les
liens qui peuvent exister en de pareils
cas et pour restaurer la confiance de
nos concitoyens nous avons besoin de
mener une politique qui soit une
politique à la fois de garanties
d'indépendance des experts et de ceux
qui sont chargés d'encadrer la mise en
place des politiques sanitaires et une
politique de transparence vis-à-vis de
la population de ce point de vue là il
ya désormais une obligation d'établir
des déclarations d'intérêt par les
personnes qui prennent part au qui
participent à des décisions sanitaire
c'est le cas de ceux qui sont membres de
cabinet par exemple des dirigeants des
agences sanitaires je souhaite
d'ailleurs que se mette en place un site
public d'information qui permettra à
chacun d'accéder à l'ensemble des
données utiles vous avez demandé s'il
existait un comité de déontologie
il existe par exemple agence nationale
de sécurité du médicament et c'est une
pratique qui doit se développer pour ce
qui est de la transparence
j'ai transmis au conseil d'état un
décret qui doit permettre de mettre en
oeuvre des mesures de transparence sur
les liens qui peuvent exister entre
l'industrie et les professionnels de
santé c'est ce qu'on appelle le décret
au sunshine act
je souhaite pour ma part que le seuil de
publication des liens qui existent entre
ces laboratoires et ses professionnels
soit le plus bas possible et que la
nature des avantages déclaré soit
accessible sur un site public unique de
cette façon monsieur le sénateur nous
parviendrons à rétablir la confiance de
tous dans
la qualité de notre système de santé
merci monsieur faut pas ça vous
souhaitez réagir
oui madame la ministre je vous remercie
pour ces réponses qui ont le mérite
d'être particulièrement clair et tout à
fait complète
il n'en reste pas moins vrai que la
place réservée à la tricherie risque
encore d'exister pendant quelques années
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
présent monsieur alain milon pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre bonjour la problématique des
ruptures d'approvisionnement de
médicaments médicaments se pose un peu
plus chaque jour d'après l'académie
nationale de pharmacie fin février 2013
près d'une soixantaine de médicaments
étaient déclarés en rupture ou en risque
de rupture de stock sur le site de
l'agencé nationale de sécurité du
médicament et des produits de santé
des solutions existent déjà allant de
l'obligation légale depuis 92 pour les
établissements pharmaceutiques
exploitante à un médicament d'informer
les autorités de santé de toute action
pouvant aboutir à la suspension de
commercialisation d'un médicament ou son
retrait du marché
à la loi sur le renforcement de la
sécurité sanitaire du 29 décembre 2011
mais malgré cette législation le
problème demeure et d'autres pistes sont
donc à explorer dans la logique du
décret du 28 du 28 septembre 2012
relatif à l'approvisionnement en
médicaments à usage humain a été mis en
place la supply chain pharmaceutique
c'est à dire la chaîne de fourniture du
médicament de la prévision des ventes à
la distanciation du médicament je
rappelle enfin contre 60 à 80 % des
matières premières utilisées pour
fabriquer des médicaments viennent
d'inde ou de chine en récemment nous
avons appris que 41% des inspections
réalisées sur les sites de fabrication
hors europe par les inspecteurs de la
direction européenne la qualité du
médicament ont abouti à une déclaration
de non conformité
madame la ministre ne devrait-on pas
modifier les règles concernant les
grossistes répartiteurs à savoir passer
d'une obligation de moyens à une
obligation de résultat cette dernière se
fonderait sur les catégories de services
à offrir par typologie médicaments
médicaments saisonniers médicaments
froid nécessitant des circuits de
distribution courts et protéger etc
face à cette situation que nous pouvons
considérer comme préoccupante pouvez
vous madame la ministre a indiqué qu à
mesure
le gouvernement compte prendre pour
pallier des ruptures d'approvisionnement
merci de marisol touraine oui monsieur
le sénateur alain milon il est vrai que
les ruptures d'approvisionnement peuvent
poser des difficultés notamment
lorsqu'il s'agit de médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur et en
2011 l' agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament et des produits de santé a
reçu cinquante et une déclaration de
rupture pour des médicaments majeurs ce
qui effectivement pose des difficultés
de ce point de vue là c'est un argument
à utiliser pour engager une politique
qui permette de relocaliser certaines
activités de production pharmaceutique
sur le territoire national cela
permettrait aussi de répondre à certains
enjeux de sécurité que vous avez
évoquées pour cela pour faire face aux
ruptures d'approvisionnement j'ai engagé
une action à deux niveaux au niveau
national et au niveau européen pour ce
qui est du niveau national vous avez
vous même fait référence au décret du 30
septembre 2012 qui prévoit un dispositif
permettant de prévenir et mieux gérer
ces ruptures ainsi ont été créés des
centres d'appels d'urgence qui par les
laboratoires qui permettent de
d'identifier les situations critiques a
été mise en place une obligation pour
les grossistes répartiteurs et pour les
laboratoires d'approvisionnement
équitable sur le territoire et la nsm
procède à la centralisation de
l'information disponible un comité de
suivi a été mis en place à ma demande
et si nous devons faire évoluer le
dispositif prévu par le décret nous le
ferons bien évidemment au niveau
européen une concertation j'ai engagé la
concertation avec mes homologues parce
que quand on parle de rupture
d'approvisionnement
c'est à l'échelle européenne que le
problème peut être traitée et j'ai donc
demandé à la commission de voir comment
nous pourrions mettre en place à la fois
un dispositif d'initiatives au niveau
européen c'est à dire de repérage
d'identification des situations à risque
et de mutualisation des moyens
disponibles pour y faire face
monsieur le sénateur c'est à la fois en
agissant au niveau national par des
moyens qui nous sont propres mais aussi
en favorisant la coopération européenne
que nous parviendrons à résorber ces
situations qui sont effectivement
préoccupantes pour certains patients
dans notre pays
merci mon cher collègue si vous
souhaitez intervenir
oui monsieur le président juste pour
remercier madame ministre me dire que je
ne doutais pas de la qualité sa réponse
mais je voulais ajouter que peut-être
que 2,2 mesure pourrait être prise sans
que cela est un coût pour la sécurité
sociale
c'est en particulier la traçabilité en
particulier des matières premières même
si il serait peut-être nécessaire de
pouvoir les rapatrier directement sur un
territoire national et mettre en place
l'obligation de résultat pour les
grossistes répartiteurs
ces deux mesures là sont déjà essentiel
pour permettre une sécurité
supplémentaire
très bien merci la parole à joël
guerriau pour le groupe
udi us et le président madame le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'industrie pharmaceutique est un
secteur clé de notre économie
mais son principal financeur c'est la
sécurité sociale qui devrait exiger en
contrepartie qu'elle adapte à la fois sa
production et rationalise ses coûts le
plus longtemps plus que la demande de
soins augmente avec le vieillissement de
la population et l'accroissement des
pathologies chroniques
or parallèlement l'industrie
pharmaceutique encouragent la
surconsommation en créant parfois des
comportements addictifs ce qui pèse bien
sûr sur les comptes sociaux et plus
encore aggravent parfois par des
conséquences néfastes
la santé publique en septembre dernier
le guide des 4000 médicaments utiles
inutiles ou dangereux des professeurs
debré et even a eu le mérite de porter
dans le débat public le problème du prix
de médicaments et de sa surconsommation
en france un problème qui a déjà été
soulevée par la cour des comptes dans
son rapport de septembre 2011 ainsi que
par notre haute assemblée dès juin 2006
puis après le drame du médiateur et
enfin le 29 décembre 2011 avec la loi
sur la sécurité sanitaire du médicament
mais le problème principal demeure la
france dépense de 1,5 à 2 fois plus que
les autres pays occidentaux en
médicaments pour un niveau de santé
comparables en cause les prix et les
volumes
ma question est donc très simple madame
le ministre
quel est le plan du gouvernement pour
mieux encadrer les prix et combattre la
surconsommation et je souhaite vous
faire part d'un exemple que j'ai vécu au
ghana loin de la capitale ma fille de 14
ans est tombé malade
un médecin lui a prescrit le nombre
exact de comprimés qui le sera de livrer
pas un de plus pas un de moins
n'est-il pas possible de promouvoir les
bonnes pratiques de prescription sur
mesure pour mettre fin au gaspillage
merci merci madame la ministre oui
monsieur le sénateur même si des progrès
ont été réalisés au cours des dernières
années
la france se caractérise encore par une
forte consommation de médicaments en
volume nous sommes au deuxième rang nous
ne sommes plus au premier ou au deuxième
rang mais en moyenne un français
consomme une boîte de médicaments par
semaine ce qui est évidemment tout à
fait excessif et nous avons une
structure de consommation ou de
prescription de médicaments qui avantage
les médicaments les plus coûteux ce qui
pèse sur les comptes de la sécurité
sociale je veux néanmoins rappelé qu' il
faut évidemment faire en sorte que les
médicaments puissent être utilisés à bon
escient et le risque avec les
publications du type de celle que vous
avez
évoquée et cueillette une défiance
généralisée qui accompagne l'ensemble
des médicaments j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire une fois ce qui avait provoqué
certains sarcasmes que les médicaments
soigner et il faut se souvenir que les
médicaments sont là pour soigner
il ne faut pas en consommer trop il ne
faut pas favoriser trop de médicaments
mais il ne faut pas faire comme si tous
les médicaments devait être écarté d'un
revers de la main donc une politique
doit être engagée qui permettent une
juste prescription cela passe aussi par
de nouvelles formations des
professionnels de santé des soutiens à
la bonne prescription et à l'aide à la
prescription
il nous faut par ailleurs engagé une
politique en faveur de l'éducation aux
médicaments c'est la raison ou une des
raisons pour lesquelles j'ai souhaité
que se mette en place une base de
données publique qui permettent de
manière transparente d'accéder à une
information fiable sur les médicaments
qui ne dépendent pas d'agents privés et
enfin il faut évidemment garantir
l'indépendance de la prescription est de
ce point de vue des mesures ont été
prises dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour garantir une
meilleure indépendance des prescripteurs
par rapport aux laboratoires et faire en
sorte que la formation des prescripteurs
ne relève plus des laboratoires c'est
avec un ensemble de mesures que nous
rétablirons la confiance et une bonne
prescription et j'aurais sans doute
ultérieurement l'occasion d'intervenir
sur la nécessité de valoriser les
médicaments génériques qui sont un des
aspects de la réponse à la situation
financière reconnaît notre pays merci
monsieur guerriau pour réagir merci
madame ministre pour cette réponse et
qui reflète bien le fait que nous soyons
en temps de surconsommation sur un
problème culturel français un réflexe
médicaments je voudrais aussi souligner
et revenir sur la question du
conditionnement du médicament parce que
ce que l'on constate en particulier dans
l'auto médicaments
lorsque les gens se soignent de même que
font-ils ils vont dans leurs stocks de
médicaments qu'ils ont conservée parce
qu'ils ont finalement beaucoup on
mélange plus ou moins bien les
médicaments et on se retrouve avec 140
mille personnes en une année qui sont
traités dans nos hôpitaux pour des
raisons comme celle ci voire 13 mille
décès ce qui n'est pas rien et qui
démontre l'importance du sujet je crois
qu'il faut revenir véritablement sur ces
questions vous l'avez dit il faut mieux
informer mais il faut aussi revenir sur
la question des quantités vendues
veiller à ce qu'il n'y ait pas d'excès
puisque ça aussi des conséquences sur la
santé publique
comme vous l'avez souligné d'où
l'importance et je voudrais souligner un
petit point particulier par exemple pour
quand nous avons la rue mme on utilise
un spray le spray le plus vendu en
france les vendus en 3 millions
d'exemplaires
ce que l'on constate pour autant c'est
que les flacons sont trop grand de en
général on a besoin pour quatre à cinq
jours et on est des flacons beaucoup
trop importants résultats bien
évidemment là cette surconsommation qui
entraîne par la suite des difficultés
comme je l'aï dit à l'instant donc un
sujet important merci madame luminaires
simon schoch qu'on la parole à monsieur
jean jacques mirassou pour le groupe
socialiste apparentés
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre l'industrie pharmaceutique dans
ce pays se porte bien et du rsa se situe
au premier rang des secteurs qui dégage
de l'excédent la concurrence en
l'occurrence des cinq milliards d'euros
par an le laboratoire sanofi est
incontestablement le vaisseau amiral
dans ce domaine il enregistre des
bénéfices qui se situe entre 5 et 9
milliards d'euros par an et que du reste
qui protège qui profite très largement
aux actionnaires tout en revendiquant à
la fois c'est vrai 2 milliards d'euros
injectés dans la r&d pourtant ce
laboratoire a annoncé pour 2015 un plan
de réorganisation ou de nombreux emplois
de la recherche seraient supprimés
notamment sur le site toulousaine les
salariés résume la situation en
déclarant qu'ils veulent une stratégie
pharmaceutique
plutôt qu'une stratégie financière
également appelée financiarisation de
l'économie qui du reste est basée sur le
profit à très court terme
cette formulation certes est lapidaire
mais
la faculté de démontrer que le danger
existe en faisant le choix de la
stratégie pharmaceutique faisons
également le choix de la placer dans le
cadre plus large de la politique de
santé celle que vous avez en charge
madame la ministre
et d'ailleurs la chose n'est pas simple
qu'elle y aura forcément pour de
multiples raisons
une évolution de l'industrie
pharmaceutique de ce qui est produit
faut-il dans le futur se résigner à ce
que les pays riches voient le marché des
médicaments dominé par les génériques en
laissant une toute petite place pour les
mots qu'une et kull innovantes dédiées à
des pathologies très ciblée ceci alors
qu'il existe on le sait chez nous en
europe et dans les pays riches des
besoins médicaux qui ne sont toujours
pas pris en compte et en même temps bien
sûr dans les pays pauvres où tout reste
à faire dans ce domaine
cette vision réductrice signoret à moyen
ou long terme
la freiner notre industrie
pharmaceutique il faut donc à mon sens
les cartes et choisir une autre voie
celle qui consiste grâce à la volonté
politique qui est la vôtre
madame la ministre a misé sur le long
terme en privilégiant la recherche et
l'innovation
il y va de notre sécurité sanitaire
ainsi que notre compétitivité
industrielle
quel est votre sentiment à ce sujet
madame la ministre merci dans le
ministre oui monsieur le sénateur
mirassou l'industrie pharmaceutique
constitue avec l'industrie de santé une
filière d'avenir pour notre pays une
filière qu'il s'agit de développer et à
laquelle nous devons permettre de parier
sur l'innovation
mais je veux vous dire que c'est en
explorant les voix de l'innovation de la
recherche du développement que ces
filières pourront se développer et pas
par le maintien
disons de marché qui ont été acquis il y
a des années qu'ils ne doivent pas
évolué de ce point de vue là le fait de
vendre des médicaments génériques permet
de dégager des ressources pour investir
dans l'innovation est recherché et créer
de nouvelles molécules l'industrie à
toulouse est un atout formidable pour ce
territoire et c'est la raison
qui a poussé le gouvernement à s'engager
fortement notamment le ministre du
redressement productif
arnaud montebourg pour que les plans de
licenciements qui étaient annoncés par
sanofi ne soit pas mise en oeuvre de
cette façon là il n'était pas acceptable
que 2500 de 1800 licenciements puisse
intervenir alors même que l'entreprise
réalise 5 milliards de bénéfices le
gouvernement a donc obtenu que
l'entreprise revoit c'est projet puisque
on parle maintenant d'un peu plus de 910
on licenciement qui ne devraient pas
être des licenciements secs et en tout
état de cause il est absolument
nécessaire que la direction de
l'entreprise est un dialogue approfondi
avec les organisations syndicales que
j'ai eu moi-même l'occasion de
rencontrer lors d'un déplacement à lyon
avec arnaud montebourg je crois que nous
devons faire le pari de l'innovation
mais avoir vraiment la volonté que cela
se fasse dans le respect des sites
industriels sanofi ne doit pas quitter
toulouse sanofi est un atout pour
toulouse
et c'est le sens de l'action du
gouvernement aujourd'hui merci monsieur
mirassou si vous le souhaitez je
remercie et madame la ministre pour
cette démonstration de l'utilité et de
volonté politique
et j'ajoute que à mon sens vous disposer
d'outils qui sont performants je pense
aux comités stratégiques de filières au
conseil stratégique des industries de
santé voire comité économique des
produits de santé seront présents parce
que quand on est mis sur la santé en
danger nos mains l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché et dans l'autre en quelque
sorte le remboursement des médicaments
donc le tout le mal que je souhaite en
industrie pharmaceutique et
singulièrement au site toulousain sait
que la conjonction de ces événements
puissions nous permettre effectivement
qu'on m'avait dit de faire le pari sur
l'avenir
et encore une fois de miser sur la
recherche et sur l'innovation
merci la parole et à madame laurence
cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je vous
profitez de l'occasion qui m'est donnée
par cette question portant sur
l'industrie pharmaceutique pour aborder
à mon tour la question du devenir des
salariés de sanofi qu'il s'agisse des
sites de toulouse comme ceux de mon
département celui du val de marne
bien que cette question puisse de prime
abord sembler concernait plus votre
collègue en charge du travail le
ministère de la santé est également
particulièrement concernée puisque à
sanofi ce sont des emplois industriels
qui seront supprimés ainsi que des
emplois de la branche recherche et
développement c'est ce que vient de
souligner mon collègue jean jacques
mirassou malgré un chiffre d'affaires de
34,9 147 milliards d'euros en 2012 dans
un contexte que tout le monde présente
comme particulièrement difficile pour la
majorité de la population
le groupe sanofi peut distribuer des
dividendes à ses actionnaires en
progression de 45% par rapport à 2011 et
sa direction se permet d'envisager comme
vous l'avez dit la suppression d'au
moins 170 emplois dans la partie
recherche et développement récemment le
13 mars dernier la cour d'appel de paris
a ordonné à la direction de sanofi de
reprendre à zéro la procédure
d'information des représentants du
personnel de la branche recherche et
développement cette destruction massive
d'emplois dans cette branche augure mal
pour l'avenir d'un groupe industriel
comme sanofi confronté à la perte du
brevet de nombreux blockbusters ces
médicaments qui rapportent au moins un
milliard de dollars 700 millions d'euros
par an à l'image de son automne en haut
de son anticoagulant vedette le plavix
dont le chiffre d'affaires avait atteint
plus de 3 milliards d'euros en 2011 sur
le sol américain
dans les deux à trois semaines qui ont
suivi la chute du brevet sanofi a perdu
près de 90 % des ventes du médicament a
constaté christian lajoux son pdg
aussi madame la ministre ma question est
la suivante quelle mesure entendez vous
prendre pour soutenir l'innovation
pharmaceutique et garantir la création
d'emplois je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
monsieur le président merci madame la
sénatrice laurence cohen comme je
l'indiquais à l'instant à votre collègue
jean jacques mirassou le gouvernement
est très attaché à ce que l'industrie
pharmaceutique puisse se développer et à
ce que cela se fasse dans le respect des
situations sociales et des implantations
locales d'ailleurs pour toulouse
une mission a été commandé à monsieur
jean pierre st tout et qui doit remettre
ses conclusions dans quelques semaines
et faire des propositions pour voir
comment peut- être maintenue à toulouse
unité de recherche qui y existent au
delà il est absolument nécessaire dans
une relation de confiance avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique mais aussi
dans une relation de coopération avec
les organisations syndicales de mettre
en oeuvre des mesures qui permettent de
qui permettent à l'industrie
pharmaceutique française de continuer à
exister au premier rang mondial pour
notre économie de ce point de vue là je
veux le dire
plusieurs mesures ont d'ores et déjà été
prises par le gouvernement et au tt a
rappelé à l'occasion de la réunion du
comité de filière des industries de
santé qui s'est tenue le 25 mars dernier
à lyon en présence d'arnaud montebourg
de geneviève fioraso et de moi-même pour
cela nous avons annoncé il ya déjà
plusieurs mois le maintien du crédit
d'impôt recherche qui vient soutenir
l'activité de recherche de l'industrie
pharmaceutique en particulier le pacte
de compétitivité qui fait l'objet de
discussions y compris de la part de
votre groupe
madame la sénatrice permet de soutenir
l'activité de développement de
l'industrie pharmaceutique comme nous
pensons que l'accord national
interprofessionnel sur l'emploi
permettra de sauvegarder des emplois et
d'aller de l'avant de la même façon nous
nous sommes engagés pour un programme
d'investissements d'avenir et le
maintien des pôles de compétitivité et
le chantier de simplification
administrative énorme
qui va engager par le gouvernement
permettra aussi de répondre aux attentes
des entreprises madame la sénatrice
l'effort de redressement de notre
économie passe par un engagement fort au
soutien de cette filière d'activité
économique dans le respect bien
évidemment du travail et de l'apport des
organisations syndicales sans lesquels
ils ne pourraient pas y avoir de
développement lui de la recherche ni de
l'activité économique
merci pour la réplique de la parole et à
madame isabelle pasquet merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre
bien sûr l'industrie pharmaceutique et
sanofi en fait n'est qu'un exemple n'est
pas épargné par la recherche effrénée de
toujours plus de compétitivité alors en
soit ce n'est pas forcément une mauvaise
chose si ce n'est que bien souvent cela
se fait au détriment de la protection
des salariés en privilégiant les
intérêts purement financiers cinq cent
mille emplois industriels ont été
détruits depuis 2008 il est urgent
d'agir pour mettre fin aux pratiques
abusives de licenciements boursiers
d'ailleurs vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
que nous avons une proposition de loi en
la matière le gouvernement propose son
projet de loi dit de sécurisation
d'emploi me direz vous mais le groupe
crc estime en tout cas ce jour que non
seulement ils ne répondent pas à
l'urgence de la situation mais en plus
ils risquent d'aggraver la précarisation
de l'emploi
par ailleurs et en ce qui concerne le
plus plat plus particulièrement la
question qui nous occupe aujourd'hui il
n'est pas acceptable que ce soit les
laboratoires qui décide ce doit être la
politique de médicaments de la recherche
et du développement
l'industrie doit être service de la
santé publique et le médicament doit
être un bien commun à l'humanité et doit
être sous contrôle public pour sa
maîtrise sociale et c'est pourquoi nous
avons la proposition de la création d'un
pôle public du médicament
merci la parole est aux mains d'hommes
aline archimbaud pour le groupe
écologiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues selon la revue prescrire
les grandes firmes pharmaceutiques
dépense environ deux fois plus en
promotion commerciale en dépenses
marketing
quant aux recherches le modèle
d'affaires dominant de ce secteur est en
effet basé
actuellement sur la promotion massive de
médicaments qui ne présentent souvent
pas d'innovation d'avant d'avancées
thérapeutiques significative
par exemple en 2009 sur 109 nouveaux
médicaments ou indications sans compter
les copies 3 apportait une avancée
thérapeutique mineurs alors que 76
n'apportaient rien de nouveau à la
pharmacopée existantes et 19 était même
considéré représenter d'éventuels
risques
dans ce contexte la recherche unique est
organisé comme une campagne
promotionnelle les données de cette
recherche sont utilisés en priorité pour
stimuler soutenir les ventes
trois stratégies sont notamment très
utilisé multiplier la publication
d'études favorables à un médicament en
utilisant la plume d'auteurs fantôme
deuxièmement ne pas publier les
résultats compromettants pour la vente
des produits au nom du secret commercial
que certaines firmes s'arroge ce droit
sachant qu'elles ne sont pas légalement
contrainte de rendre publiques les
données obtenues lors des essais
cliniques et troisièmement intimider les
chercheurs indépendants les lanceurs
d'alertés gênant cette pratique et en
plus répandu qu'on ne le croit ces trois
types de pratiques sont répandues madame
la ministre ne pensez vous pas que dans
un état de droit
nous avons besoin de faire confiance aux
résultats de la recherche clinique et
donc une recherche plus indépendante
libérée des contraintes commerciales est
nécessaire afin de faire progresser la
médecine et donc ne pensez vous pas qu
un financement public de la recherche
dans ce secteur soit nécessaire je vous
remercie la parole à madame marisol
touraine
oui merci madame la sénatrice aline
archimbaud la france peut à juste titre
s'en enorgueillir de la qualité de sa
recherche clinique et je veux ici saluer
le travail remarquable de nos chercheurs
qu'ils travaillent dans des laboratoires
privés ou dans des laboratoires publics
la france est au deuxième ou au
troisième rang selon les années pour le
nombre d'essais cliniques réalisés
et nous avons ce beau résultat en partie
grâce à des programmes d'engagement
public qui sont tout à fait significatif
une grande partie de la recherche
aujourd'hui se développent dans des
laboratoires privés
donc on ne peut pas faire comme si cette
réalité là n'existait pas à les trois
quarts de la recherche en matière de
sofas sont les médicaments de la
recherche clinique sur les médicaments
se fait dans les laboratoires
industriels et à un quart est menée par
la recherche académique il est donc
important de garantir la qualité de la
recherche quel que soit le lieu où elle
se développe et non pas d'avoir une
vision qui serait une vision opposant
recherche publique et recherche privée
car c'est un des atouts et une des
réalités de la france une des raisons
pour lesquelles la france a su
développer des programmes reconnus
c'est la mise en place par le
gouvernement de pierre bérégovoy il y a
vingt ans d'un plan de spie taille et de
recherche clinique qui a permis de mener
à bien cinq mille projets de recherche
sur lesquels ont été investi près de 900
millions d'euros 870 millions d'euros ce
programme va être encore améliorée il a
d'ores et déjà permis à certaines
recherches de déboucher sur des
améliorations thérapeutique
significatives notamment en matière
génétique par exemple les bébés bulles
n'ont plus besoin de vivre dans des
bulles grâce à de la recherche financée
de cette façon là nous devons donc
travailler à la transparence à
l'indépendance de la recherche ou
qu'elles se développent mais je veux le
dire madame la sénatrice la france peut
être fière de sa recherche clinique
aujourd'hui car elle est un de nos
atouts au niveau européen merci madame
la sénatrice
vous souhaitez réagir je vous remercie
madame la ministre pour votre réponse
précise il ne s'agit pas d'opposer les
secteurs mais je continue à penser que
en tout cas sur certains points qui
peuvent être à un moment donné jugés
prioritaires sensible en matière de
santé publique
il peut être intéressant que que le
gouvernement porter de l'intérêt général
stimule la recherche à propos d'un
médicament précis on l'a vu dans le
temps des débats budgétaires l'année
dernière et je voulais insister sur le
fait qu'il s'agit pas d'opposer les deux
types de recherche mais qu' une
recherche publique pas financée par les
pouvoirs publics dans certains cas pour
arbitrer aussi dans certains contentieux
peut être utile je remercie très bien la
parole est à présent madame catherine
procaccia pour le groupe ump
merci merci mes chers collègues madame
la ministre
au cours des vingt dernières années les
circuits de fabrication du médicament
ont complètement changé d'une
fabrication quasiment nationale des
principes actifs excipients par un petit
nombre d'acteurs identifiés et connus
des autorités
l'importation des médicaments a
littéralement explosé
la france importe pour près de 22
milliards d'euros de médicaments contre
9 milliards en l'an 2000 un rapport de
l'académie de médecine indiqué que 50%
des princeps et 80% des principes actifs
des génériques et est dorénavant
fabriquées en asie le cas du paracétamol
est particulièrement frappant cet
antidouleur le plus vendu au monde est
fabriqué à 100 % hurd
hors d'europe les changements
économiques ont été si rapide que le
seul contrôle des autorités compétentes
ne peut plus sécurisé la fabrication des
médicaments
en effet là et même est une simple
procédure d'accès sur le marché et les
contrôles effectués par le mehdi par le
fabricant se font par des évaluations
ils ne sont donc forcément pas exhaustif
qui plus est
énorme de bonnes pratiques ne sont pas
harmonisées dans le monde car elles sont
très coûteuses et donc forcément pas
appliquée tel est le cas de l'héparine
qui a beaucoup défrayé la chronique
quant au contrôle sur les sites ils sont
trop hexagonaux sur 896 inspection en
2010 seulement 85 concernaient des sites
étrangers
certes à partir de juillet pour lutter
contre les imports de principes actifs
frauduleux les laboratoires devront
fournir une attestation de conformité
aux critères européens pour tous les
produits importés mais celle ci sera
établi par les pays exportateurs
eux-mêmes et ne réglera donc pas la
question de la méfiance et à l'absence
de contrôle actuellement seul le nom du
titulaire exploitants figure sur
l'emballage
personne ne connaît donc l'origine des
matières premières ni si le médicament a
subi des contrôles madame la ministre
elle vous favorable à l'inscription sur
les boîtes de l'origine des matières
premières ainsi que du pays de
conditionnement et quelles mesures
comptez vous prendre pour encourager les
industriels du médicament notamment
génériques à rétablir la confiance mais
alors si la parole à madame marisol
touraine
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice catherine procaccia je vous
remercie de la manière dont vous avez
posé la question très mesuré dans un
climat qui risque toujours de déraper
moi je veux le dire avec beaucoup de
force
nos concitoyens doivent avoir confiance
dans la qualité des médicaments qui leur
sont proposées ce n'est pas parce que il
y a eu des fraudes
ce n'est pas parce que il y a des
interrogations où il y a eu des
interrogations sur certains médicaments
qu'il faut jeter l'opprobre sur
l'ensemble de la production
pharmaceutique et de ce point de vue là
les médicaments génériques
sont des médicaments dans lesquels on
peut avoir confiance il y a qu'en france
que l'on s'interroge sur la qualité des
médicaments génériques qui sont
fabriqués dans les mêmes conditions
j'insiste là dessus dans les mêmes
conditions que les médicaments princeps
il est exact qu au cours des dernières
années la production des matières
premières s'est déplacé dans des pays
hors union européenne en particulier en
asie mais c'est également vrai pour les
matières premières qui composent les
médicaments princeps et donc tout
l'enjeu est à la fois de favoriser la
relocalisation de certaines activités de
production sur le territoire européen et
si possible sur le territoire national
et une discussion est engagée avec la
filière pharmaceutique précisément dans
le cadre du comité de filière pour voir
comment nous pouvons pour les
médicaments et des filières stratégiques
faire en sorte que la production soit
relaxe relocaliser dans notre pays et
nous devons par ailleurs c'est le
deuxième axe de travail faire en sorte
que les contrôles la garantie de
contrôle efficace soit renforcé ses
contrôles ils sont menés au niveau
européen ils sont menés au niveau
national des normes sont imposés qui se
diffuse progressivement au niveau
mondial c'est ainsi que nous
parviendrons à rétablir la confiance et
au delà une réflexion est engagée avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique pour voir
jusqu'à quel point des informations
pourraient être apportés aux patients
qui n'est pas qu'un consommateur qui est
impatient jusqu'à quel point des
informations pourraient lui être
apportés directement sur la boîte
lorsqu'ils achètent cette boîte ces
discussions sont en cours et je pense
que nous pourrons aboutir à des mesures
destinées à renforcer encore une fois la
confiance de nos concitoyens
merci ma progression merci madame la
ministre
entre votre réponse à la mi longs et à
la mienne vous répondez en partie à la
question puisque nous estimons aussi que
s'il ya des problèmes
d'approvisionnement c'est bien parce que
les principes actifs et les médicaments
proviennent beaucoup
de très loin et que lorsqu'il y à des
contrôles dans ces pays là justement ça
retarde les fournisseurs et ça pose un
vrai problème pour des médicaments
beaucoup plus important que qu'un
certain nombre de médicaments qui sont
en france il y avait auparavant il ya
encore en france 224 usines de
fabrication il y en avait beaucoup plus
dans l'an 2000
et malheureusement sur les 47
médicaments qui ont été autorisés sur le
marché européen l'année dernière aucun
n'était fabriqué en france donc vous
parler de re laquelle relocalisation de
travail avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
je crois effectivement que ramener un
certain nombre d' usine en france de
fabrication en france et aussi
permettent à ces entreprises et à
saintes des industries de proposer des
nouveaux médicaments irait dans le bon
sens très bien merci la parole est à
présent monsieur jean luc fichet pour le
groupe socialiste apparentés
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues l'industrie
pharmaceutique est aujourd'hui regardés
avec méfiance
le doute s'est installé dans l'esprit du
consommateur et cela pour deux raisons
la première c'est que nombre de produits
proposés sont des produits de
laboratoire des médicaments cosmétiques
qui n'apportent rien aux malades
leur particularité à ces médicaments
c'est qu'il coûte cher et participe à la
bonne santé de nos balles en laboratoire
et parallèlement au déficit de la
sécurité sociale
la seconde concerne la confusion qui est
de plus en plus grande dans la
perception du consommateur
comment comprendre qu'un traitement pour
le diabète est prescrit comme coupe faim
il faut être en bonne santé pour y
comprendre quelque chose
face à ce doute les réactions sont
multiples passions de garde sa confiance
en son médecin et dans son pharmacien
mais elle s'autorise de plus en plus à
intervenir sur la prescription exprimant
auprès de son médecin ou de son
pharmacien en cas d'auto médication le
souhait de prendre des produits les
moins chimique possible tout ce qui est
à base de plantes est beaucoup mieux
perçue surtout chez les jeunes et les
catégories de population qui se
documente et souhaite prendre soin d'eux
de façon plus naturelle
beaucoup de médecins sont à l'écouté de
leurs patients est de plus en plus
fréquemment
on assiste à des prescriptions de
préparations magistrales tout
particulièrement quand il s'agit de
porter remède à des désagréments ou des
troubles bénins
je pense aux troubles du sommeil de la
digestion ou douleurs articulaires etc
les pharmaciens sont tout à fait apte à
répondre à cette demande de préparations
magistrales
certains ont même fait la démarche de
formation complémentaire pour une
parfaite maîtrise de ces préparations
c'est pourquoi madame la ministre je
souhaite savoir s'il est dans vos
intention d'étudier le remboursement de
ces mêmes préparation par la sécurité
sociale
je précise que ces remboursements existe
encore il ya peu avant que le ministre
ce gain ne les supprime
il ne s'agit pas bien sûr de créer une
nouvelle dépense de la sécurité sociale
surtout pas mais bien de répondre à une
nouvelle demande de nos jeunes
populations une volonté de se soigner
mieux et de manière moins coûteuses afin
d'être certain cette proposition n'est
pas une nouvelle dépense de sécurité
sociale mais une alternative à une
certaine médication trop coûteuse
je suggère pas réellement de restreindre
les remboursements de nombreux
médicaments dont l'inutilité est avérée
et déjà répertoriés dans des ouvrages
d'éminents spécialistes de santé
proposition d'élargir le déremboursement
de se faire avec un accompagnement des
malades et avec l'objectif général
d'être mieux plus de charge par la
médecine allopathique collègues
le temps est compté la réponse de madame
la ministre inter jean-luc fichet
j'entends bien votre préoccupation et
votre volonté de répondre aux attentes
d'une partie de la population
pour autant je tiens à dire avec un peu
de force que nous ne pouvons pas faire
comme si les médicaments n'avaient pas
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux
représenter des avancées considérables
et aujourd'hui là des enjeux auxquels
nous sommes confrontés par exemple avec
la résistance aux antibiotiques c'est la
capacité à maintenir des traitements
qu'ils soient des traitements efficaces
et donc je veux
vous dire que l'utilisation des
préparations magistrales qui sont des
médicaments préparés par les pharmaciens
ne peuvent être réalisées que en
l'absence de spécialités pharmaceutiques
disponibles disposant d'une autorisation
de mise sur le marché ou même d'une
autorisation temporaire d'utilisation
ces préparations ne sont pas aujourd'hui
évalué et ne font pas l'objet d'une
appréciation en terme de bénéfice risque
et donc il faut être extraordinairement
prudents quant à leurs prescriptions qui
relève de la seule responsabilité du
médecin et du pharmacien qui les
préparent et les délivrer donc il s'agit
de perspectives ou de possibilité qui ne
peuvent rester que c'est exceptionnel
pour autant monsieur le sénateur j'ai
envie de vous dire que nous avons tous à
certains moments pour des comment dire
des problèmes bénins eu recours à des
préparations naturelles pour reprendre
votre vocabulaire cela s'est toujours
fait cela continuera de se faire et un
médecin peut prescrire y compris de
prendre telle ou telle du miel quand on
a mal à la gorge ou de prendre une
tisane pour telle ou telle chose mais
cela doit rester marginale ne peut
rester que marginal et je vous le dis le
seul sénateur il me paraît par respect
pour vous il me paraît difficile
d'envisager que la sécurité sociale
procède au remboursement de ces
prescriptions
si monsieur le sénateur quel slogan
quelques secondes oui merci madame la
ministre de votre réponse je voulais
simplement reprendre ce qui a été dit
précédemment c'est que la recherche et
l'innovation sont au coeur un petit peu
de ce qui fait la france aujourd'hui
l'industrie pharmaceutique et je pense
que effectivement c'est aussi un secteur
de recherche que l'on peut continuer à
explorer parce qu'il ya là une vraie
demande
parce qu'il ya là aussi une source de
soins et je crois que ce n'est pas mal
de mettre le patient au coeur des
préoccupations de nos prochaines de
santé et de notre industrie
pharmaceutique
je vous remercie très bien merci la
question suivante la dernière question
pour monsieur philippe darniche
pour la réunion administrative de ses
soeurs ses préférences et madame la
ministre je suis opposé deux bref
question la première a déjà déposé par
un certain nombre de mes collègues
elle concerne la traçabilité des
médicaments génériques fabriqués à
l'étranger sujet majeur aujourd'hui 60 à
80% des principes actifs pharmaceutiques
utilisé et vendu en europe sont
fabriqués hors espace économique
européen provenance essentiellement nous
savons tous de chine ou d'inde
face à cette mondialisation qui conduit
à une multiplication des acteurs
intervenant dans la fabrication de ces
médicaments
il semble impossible d'inspecter
régulièrement toute la chaîne de
fabrication de toutes les matières
premières et vous même en avait parlé
ce site est très inquiétant des
initiatives européennes de contrôle et
d'inspection géré par l' agence
européenne de médicaments et par la
direction européenne la qualité de
médicaments et des soins de santé
n'apporte pas des garanties suffisantes
or les témoignages des médecins note des
différences de résultats thérapeutiques
constatée entre le princeps et
génériques
on ne peut pas à la fois demandé aux
médecins et aux pharmaciens de délivrer
pour des raisons économiques sécurité
sociale de délivrer des génériques ne
pas garantir leur fiabilité
ma question pouvez-vous nous préciser
l'action du gouvernement sur ce sujet ma
deuxième question concerne les enjeux
financiers tournant autour de la
recherche de l'embryon grâce aux travaux
du professeur yamanaka prix nobel de
médecine nous savons produire et
entretenir des cellules y ps en grande
quantité qui aujourd'hui peuvent être
produites sans anomalie ces cellules
sont plus en plus utilisés à la place
des cellules souches embryonnaires
humaines pour la recherche notamment bon
ce qui concerne l'industrie
pharmaceutique à savoir la modélisation
du des pathologies et de criblage de
molécules des recherches les plus
récentes montrent que les i ps donne les
mêmes résultats évitant ainsi le
problème éthique d'utiliser les cellules
du vivant l'ampleur des investissements
aujourd'hui de l'industrie
pharmaceutique semblerait indiquer qu'
elle souhaiterait que lent que la
recherche l'embryon humain soit
rapidement autorisés en aujourd'hui les
raisons scientifiques de se justifie
plus n'étant pas favorable à cette
colonisation des cellules embryonnaires
alors que les cellules et ps apporte des
solutions tout aussi fiables
je souhaiterais madame la ministre
connaître dans ce contexte la position
du gouvernement madame la ministre
monsieur le sénateur philippe darniche
je voudrais revenir pour commencer sur
la question de la fiabilité la
traçabilité des matières premières qui
composent nos médicaments je veux redire
ici avec une certaine solennité que les
matières premières qui sont utilisées
dans la composition des médicaments g et
celles qui sont utilisées dans la
composition la fabrication des
médicaments princeps ont la même origine
et ce sont les mêmes les processus de
fabrication sont pas nécessairement
identiques mais les matières premières
sont les mêmes et donc les
interrogations que vous portez et que
j'entends parce qu'elles sont légitimes
ce le sénateur mais les interrogations
que vous portez sur la traçabilité des
matières premières entrant dans la
fabrication des médicaments génériques
sont aussi applicables est valable pour
la traçabilité des médicaments princeps
et c'est donc à la la fiabilité de notre
système de production de médicaments
tout entier que nous devons nous
attacher avec le renforcement des
mécanismes de contrôle les procédures de
contrôle telles qu'elles existent au
niveau européen ou au niveau national et
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que des
règles de bonnes pratiques se diffuse
désormais au niveau international c'est
un point tout à fait important à travers
l'inspection des sites l'inspection ils
situent des matières premières fabriquer
et puis ensuite des inspections sur les
lieux de fabrication du médicament fini
sur le deuxième aspect de la question
que vous avez indiquée il y à une
discussion dont j'espère qu'elle pourra
se poursuivre sur la recherche sur les
embryons c'est un enjeu tout à fait
majeur pour la recherche
et je crois que nous aurions
collectivement à gagner à ce que d'abord
la discussion puisse mener à son être
menée à son terme et je ne crois pas que
sur un sujet d'une telle importance
les mesures dilatoires et d'obstruction
et beaucoup
sens la recherche monsieur le sénateur
vous en conviendrez puisque le débat a
eu lieu ici la recherche française en
particulier mais la recherche en général
mérite mieux que des manoeuvres
d'obstruction
merci chers collègues si vous souhaitez
réagir ont terminé merci je réagirais
simplement sur le premier point madame
le ministre pour dire qu' il y à un
chiffre qui est quand même parlant
puisque 41% des contrôles européens
conduisent à une non conformité des
médicaments des génériques c'est
considérable et donc j'entends
parfaitement ce que vous dites par
rapport à l'utilisation des matières
premières il y à des processus de
fabrication qui sont incontestablement
différents noeuds bouton pas ne peut en
fonction des pays bien sûr
ne peut-on pas faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une harmonisation de ces processus
merci mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance sera reprise dans
quelques minutes pour l'examen du projet
de loi donc pour ces questions cribles
autour de l'industrie pharmaceutique que
vous avez pu suivre en direct sur notre
antenne
on se retrouve dans quelques instants
pour le début au sénat de la séance sur
le mariage pour tous a tout de suite